Speaker 1: The Fox News text message leaks have
gone nuclear and the latest tranche reveals that
Tucker Carlson hates Trump passionately
despite acting on his show like he thinks
Trump is a reasonable person and hanging out
with Trump outside of work and pretending to
like him as well. This exposes so many different
layers of the insanity that is right wing media,
the right wing movement and the MAGA movement in
the United States. And we're going to look at all
of it. But let's start with what we learned.
Huffington Post reports Tucker Carlson Exposed
says he hates Trump, quote, passionately in
private texts. The Fox News host said he deplored
the former president in private and wished for the
day he could ignore him. These are text messages
from right before the Trump riots. Text messages
from January 4th, 2021. We are going to look at a
number of different messages. These, again have
been revealed in connection with the Dominion
Voting Systems lawsuit for defamation against Fox
News. Take a look at this, Tucker. Texting with
an unknown person. We are very, very close to
being able to ignore Trump most nights. I truly
can't wait. The person that Tucker is texting with
says I want nothing more. It does feel very, very
close. I imagine things will get nice starting
around mid-February. To which Tucker Carlson
responds, I hate him passionately. I blew up at
Peter Navarro today in frustration. I actually
like Peter, but I can't handle much more of
this. Tucker hates Trump, and we will get to the
hypocrisy and interest of this very, very soon.
Tucker and Laura Ingraham also texting. And it
is fascinating. Laura Ingraham saying to Tucker
Friday numbers aren't that surprising with Trump
impending loss. But how much of the bleed is
due to anger at the news channel? This is Laura
texting Tucker about the decline in ratings right
around that time, right after the election in
November of 2020. Tucker says. Oh, a lot meaning
a lot of the ratings decline is because of
people angry that the news side of Fox called the
election for Biden, and rightly so. Laura says, My
anger at the news channel is pronounced and Tucker
says it should be. We devote our lives to building
an audience and they let chris wallace and leland
effing vittert wreck it too much. Tucker mad
at chris wallace because chris wallace
actually said some uncontroversial truths.
And then in a third one hear tucker carlson
saying the downside of the business of the
news business is that a lot of the time you don't
get to choose the news, but you're required to
react to it. So we actually do our in our salaries
now then. Oh, sorry, This is from a from unknown
person. They pitch a podcast to Tucker saying one
thought I had today is a joint venture of sorts
between Tucker Carlson LLC and Fox News podcast
generally are free and ad supported. We could
have a Fox backed podcast promoted on channel,
etc. that has one free episode a week and we
can repurpose Tucker Carlson dot com to host the
podcast and create a Tucker Carlson podcast app,
blah blah, blah, blah blah. We get people to,
to subscribe, etc., etc. and basically pitching
a business to Tucker Carlson while all of this
insane discussion is going on and he's furious
with Trump and he hates him passionately and
on and on and on, these are merely actors and
entertainers. Okay. Now, as a reminder, of
course, here is Tucker. A few months ago,
hanging out with Trump at a golf tournament and
Tucker and Marjorie Taylor GREENE also, they look
like they're having a grand old time with Trump.
So this is not a trivial thing to understand.
Sometimes people think, you know, David, it's
like there's what you do and there's the Young
Turks and there's Fox. News and there's all this
different stuff. It's all the same. It is not all
the same. Tucker is more like a character in
a movie on his show, someone who will pretend
whatever to maintain the show and the salary that
comes with it, to maintain ratings and to maintain
access to power. In this case, access to power
means being able to hang around Trump, have Trump
on whatever the case may be. I believe the things
I say. I'm not playing a character on this show,
and I think that you will find that this is the
case with just about everybody that, you know,
I would consider a colleague that is sort of in
the field in the business that I'm in. Of online
left wing political commentary and analysis. When
I tell you something on the show, I'm not playing
a character. And sometimes people in my audience
don't like it. For example, last week, in the
week before, I did clips telling you I'm not super
interested in this Marianne Williamson candidacy,
I find her New Age spiritual stuff to be nonsense.
I don't think she's going to do anything to push.
Biden left. I'm not really entertained or
interested or think that the entire thing is
a super valuable thing. It would be easier for
me to do the things some other shows do, which
is to say this is incredibly important. Marianne
Williamson. Williamson is an important voice and
she is a valuable participant in the Democratic
primary. And once she gets on the debate stage
with Joe Biden, she's going to show people how
valuable. That would be me lying to you and
playing a character, and I would get praise for
doing that. If you look online, you know, Jesse
Dallimore has been critical of Marianne Williamson
and he's getting attacked on Twitter. It would be
easier for me to play the character. Okay. But I
don't do that. I just tell you what I think. And
sometimes there are repercussions and sometimes
people get mad and sometimes people tune out.
Fox News. We've now learned Tucker hates Trump but
was still playing up all of the election lies and
he hangs out with Trump, etc.. Sean HANNITY didn't
believe any of the nonsense he was spouting.
Laura Ingraham didn't believe the nonsense she was
spouting, drowning his own country to make a buck.
Now, will this affect Tucker's audience in the
sense that now they know the guy? I'm a Trump fan,
and I watch Tucker to get the news about him.
Now that they know Tucker actually hates Trump.
Are they going to tune out or will they even
know that Tucker hates Trump? Maybe not.